caller from the eight one three area
code if you can hear me eight one three
tell us who you are tell me what your
question is hi can you hear me
we can hear you okay good I just had to
switch my phone off of speaker on the
neck sir thank you no I hope your
phone's when you call radio shows I love
it yeah all right hi my name's Andrew
from Tampa Florida great my question oh
go ahead what's on your mind today
Andrew oh sorry um actually I had um but
my main question is I was kind of
curious just I don't know if you've
mentioned it on an earlier show or maybe
a show that I just missed when you said
it I was kind of curious what your
thoughts are like wait what your I don't
know if I'm gonna say this correctly
your yeah what's the real button sim in
the simplest possible terms what's your
question
Oh what-what would you define your
economic ideology aka you know would you
be like a staunch capitalist you know
maybe more of a socialist just along
that line just based on some of the
guests I I couldn't quite I've been kind
of curious myself based on the guest
you've had you know which end of the
spectrum you're on yeah so I I am more
aligned with the regulated capitalism
that exists in socially democratic
countries like Scandinavia those are the
simplest terms in which I could sort of
give you the most general overview of my
economic views okay yeah and that makes
sense I was just it was kind of curious
you know just uh after some of the
interviews I watched with Richard Wolff
for instance I started looking into his
background and thought he's a staunch
socialist and you know then you had I
can't remember her name and I do
apologize to her the person you had on
about Modern
yes modern monetary theory Pavlina
chernev oh we interviewed her last week
that's right yes that's it yes yes I'm
just kind of curious good I mean I guess
sir I don't really have much insight
into your political economic
philosophies Yeah right I might be
interviewing I interview guests with all
sorts of economic views and it wouldn't
necessarily relate to mine all right
Andrew very good thank you good to hear
from you glad we were able to get that
cleared up